today we're going to talk about the
biggest time wasters in law school and
how to avoid them for better grades so
stick around and get an edge in law
school okay
time waster number one this is the one
that most students lose the most amount
of time on and those are case briefs
these things are huge wastes of time
these are the multicolored bastards that
will suck up all of your time in their
first semester in law school you're
summarizing all of the cases that your
law professor provides to you all
because you might have seen it on TV or
on Legally Blonde these are the biggest
waste of time we have a whole video
devoted to why case briefs are a bad
idea but the bottom line is that you
just can't use the information that
you're summarizing out of your law
school cases on your final exam don't
waste your time on case briefs there are
better ways of reading your cases you
can do it faster you can do it more
efficiently in fact we have an entire
ebook devoted specifically to how to
read your cases we give it away for free
you can get the link below time-waster
number two preparing for in class cold
calling law school is known for the
Socratic method
in other words cold calling on students
to describe their cases or to explain
different nuances of different legal
situations for many people this is
terrifying but as terrifying as it is
it's also completely useless there is
almost a zero percent chance that you're
going to use what another student has
said in class on your final you should
prepare for class in the sense that you
want to try and get a handle on the law
that's going to be discussed but it's
just not worth the diminishing returns
of preparing for the off chance that you
might get cold called in class time
waster number three trying to impress
your professor
unlike college participation rarely
counts for anything in law school
so don't go into class trying to impress
your professor don't go into office
hours thinking that by discussing the
cases with your professor you're going
to impress them and be able to talk up
your grade it's just not going to happen
if you do go into office hours
do it for yourself try to understand
something that you weren't able to
understand before but don't go into
office hours thinking that you're going
to impress the professor and therefore
get a better grade be wary of showing
off in class it's hard to listen when
you're talking Stephen Covey said most
people do not listen with the intent to
understand they listen with the intent
to reply and I see that in law school
all the time if your mouth is open your
ears are closed so don't try to impress
your professor by the same token another
time waster is trying to impress your
friends a general rule in law school
don't be a douche and don't be a gunner
Gunners tend to do poorly in class and
that's because when you're talking
you're not listening so it's better to
listen in class don't try to impress
your friends don't try to impress them
in a study group just listen you'll be
better off for it and that brings me to
time waster number five which is trying
to memorize the detail of cases other
than just the rule or the facts we can
spend an infinite amount of time trying
to memorize every single nuance of the
case but for the most part your
professor is going to explain the most
important parts of that case there's no
point in trying to memorize every single
detail outside of what your professor
provides so listen when your professor
is talking about the cases and certainly
pay attention to the facts of the case
and the bright-line rule if the case
happens to provide that but other than
that similar to case briefing it's not
worth your time and trying to memorize
every single portion of the cases that
you discuss or the history of the law or
other legal aspects that you'll find in
commercial outlines which brings me to
time waster number 6 which is looking
for the right answer in law school you
have to be ok with ambiguity everything
is one big gray area in fact and realize
the cases that go to trial are the ones
that could go either way if a case is an
easy one
but it will settle before hand and in
law school you're going to be faced with
ambiguous situation after ambiguous
situation you have to come to great
with the idea that there may not be a
right answer you may have to go with the
least bad answer or you may have to deal
with differing shades of gray either way
you can't waste your time by trying to
find the right answer metaphysics has no
place in law school be comfortable with
uncertainty and it will be your friend
and you'll actually be able to use it to
great effect in law school exams so if
you can avoid those six time wasters
you're going to be off to a great start
and you're going to have an edge on
everybody else oh and by the way if you
want to get better grades on your next
law school final check this out we put
together a free ebook called the
ultimate guide to crushing law school
finals just click the link below to
download you'll show you exactly how to
prepare for your next final including
how to plan how to outline and how to
study for your next file just click
below also if you like this video please
subscribe to our Channel we come out
with new videos on how to crush law
school all the time so thanks from
everyone here at legal eagle
[Music]
you
[Music]